Hi everyone.
As some of you may know, but others will not.
It's been a long while since I put up any new content on this YouTube channel,
I've been suffering from impaired health,
severely impaired health,
as a consequence of benzodiazepine use for
anxiety or more accurately from a combination of using that
medication and then ceasing its use.
Once I realized it was dangerous, um,
that's put me in and out of hospitals for much of the last year
in Connecticut, in the United States, in Toronto,
in Canada, in Moscow, in Russia,
and in Belgrade Serbia.
As.
My family searched for specialists who could aid me in this severe
post use withdrawal and neurological damage
related consequences of both the benzodiazepine use and,
and its cessation. Um,
I started taking it in 2016, 2017,
early 2017, according to the prescribed,
um,
recommendations and really never give it a second thought. Uh,
that was a mistake, um, to say the least.
Anyways.
I've learned some things during that trying time, I suppose, or at least I've,
I can tell you what kept me going during what was certainly the
worst period of my life. Um,
family that's for sure. Uh,
friends and the work I was able to continue doing.
So I was able to continue writing, um,
something that all talk about probably within the next month,
my family, my wife, Tammy, my son,
Julian, and his wife Chilean, and my daughter McKayla and her husband,
Andre have been of inestimable value to me and provided me with tremendous
support during this period. Um,
McKayla and Andre accompanied me to Russia and to Serbia.
Uh, both of those episodes were extremely grueling and lasted for months.
Um,
but I'm alive and I have plans for the future.
I want to thank those people from the bottom of my heart,
my extended family and friends, whom I will name elsewhere,
went above and beyond the call of duty. In my estimation,
I certainly not convinced that I would have the character to provide to
any one of them, what they provided to me. So was a humbling lesson,
I suppose. Um, my work,
this sort of work,
although it was all writing and not video production was also extremely useful
because I could sustain myself by producing
and then calling through thoughts that were helpful,
despite my anguish, I suppose,
and my lack of hope for the future. Um,
hopefully we'll see,
but hopefully much of that is behind me and I can return
to something resembling a normal life.
I can tell you what my plans are for video production,
at least for the next while I completed a
biblical series devoted to Genesis in fall of
2017. And that has proved very popular.
I it's a strange word to use for a lecture series like that. Um,
I'm going to start working on the next book in the old Testament,
which is Exodus, but in that will take awhile. But in the interim,
I think I'm going to produce videos devoted to Proverbs the book of wisdom
essentially, or a book of wisdom. Um, you've all heard,
no doubt that wisdom is proverbial is that,
or that there's such a thing as proverbial wisdom. And that
phrase stems from the book of Proverbs,
which are single sentence aphorisms
imparting some truth.
I think the analysis of those which can be done in a relatively short period
of time will prove of benefit to me and perhaps to those who are
inclined to watch or listen to my analysis. Um,
I would also like to thank all of you for
continuing to support my work.
I have far more followers on YouTube and Instagram and Twitter
for that matter than I did before I became ill.
And my book has sold very well in, in multiple languages.
And that's really amazing and remarkable. And.
I hope that.
What I produce in the future will
That people will find it of equal or greater
utility. That's an ambitious hope given how much attention,
what I've produced before has garnered, but.
It.
Still seems appropriate and appropriate goal for my upcoming
activities.
I guess I could let you all know as well that.
We've put.
Together. This is an initiative that was spearheaded by McKayla and Andre.
We've put together the ability to translate the YouTube lectures into
a variety of languages. I think it's six at the moment.
Six will be ruled out over the next few months,
professionally translated dubbed because our analysis
indicated that in most of these markets,
dubbed videos are preferred to subtitle videos.
And so that will provide the opportunity
for the ideas I've been developing. Um,
many of which I have derived from other sources to be sure.
To.
Have an impact beyond the English language speaking world.
Uh, there seems to be some desire for that.
Um, my book, my last book,
12 rules for life sold 300,000 copies in
South Korea, for example,
which very much surprised me because I wasn't sure that the ideas well
first were translatable, but we're going to be.
Acceptable.
Uh, in a culture with such a different developmental background.
Anyways, I'm not going to make this a long video.
I wanted to tell you that I'm back in Toronto, that I'm in much better health,
although it's still severely impaired, especially in the morning. Um,
but I can work again and I really want to, um,
and that to let you know that with God's grace and
mercy, um,
I'll be able to start generating original
material once again and pick up where I left off.
Um, thank you very much.
And.
Well, thank you very much. It's probably sufficient.
Bye-bye.